question is to both the players  could you reveal some of the preparation  that was done and the seconds  on the team now that the match is over  if possible  well  i think i have already said that you  know the team is probably  more or less the same as  as it was in uh  in april  so  being given a chance i'd just like to  thank the team for the amazing work and  yeah i apologize literally it didn't  result into something more  impressive  thanks um yeah absolutely for me as well  i'd like to to thank my team for doing  an  amazing job  both obviously to um  to peter uh who is who's here and um  to all of the the others at  different locations  for me it was  uh  yeah i think  everybody from um  from the last match  was there except for uh  for neil scandellos  nils for checking you there  uh you did a wonderful job in  2000  2016 and 18 though um  and a couple of a couple of new people  as well